[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 2 décembre
depuis lundi 30 novembre le projet rer
vélo est lancé c'est un réseau de 650 km
de pistes cyclables sécurisées qui
pourrait être inaugurée en partie dès
nous ferons le point avec le
coordinateur du projet issu du collectif
vélos ile de france vincent de golf dans
l'actualité également tous les
personnels des crèches de et de la
classe pardon réservé aux enfants
autistes sont désormais équipés de
masques transparence et la municipalité
d'elancourt qui a fourni les équipements
et puis trois anciens établissements
scolaires de montigny le bretonneux
auront une deuxième vie la ville vient à
le pardon a déjà lancé deux gros
chantiers
[Musique]
avant de recevoir vincent de gough
coordinateur du projet rer vélo du
collectif vélos ile de france
le tracé du rer vélo a été dévoilé en
partie ce lundi 30 novembre lors d'une
conférence de presse organisée par la
région ile-de-france et le collectif
vélos qui regroupe 38 associations
s'il ya guettent son goût bonsoir soir
vous avez vous avec nous pour parler de
ce projet et il y a cinq premières
lignes prioritaires qui ont été données
lors de cette réunion
oui c est une première étape du rer v
réseau express régional vélo la région
ile-de-france veut pousser ces habitants
à utiliser ce mode de transport
les premiers comités de pilotage ont
donc été mise en place concernant cinq
lignes sur neuf nommés de a à e
comme vous pouvez le voir sur la carte
la b3 paris massy saclay plaisir passera
par trappe et se terminera donc à
plaisir est là à un paris la défense
cergy-pontoise passera par sartrouville
et conflans sainte honorine dont le
détail est donné par philippe wullens et
membre du collectif du travail du rer ça
va emprunter un trajet qui l empruntent
le pont le nouveau pont sur et hall en
chemin de fer et hall à houilles ça va
rejoindre sartrouville et ça va
traverser à maisons laffitte
il ya toute la traversée de la forêt
jusqu'au pont la passe à la passerelle
de conflans la passerelle jaune de
conflans sous le pont de la 195 qui est
une passerelle piétons vélos ensuite on
ronge les quais jusqu'au pont de fin
d'oise pour entrer dans la ville
d'andrésy et prendre les quais en
direction de morcourt et alors ce projet
célia doit répondre à plusieurs
objectifs dont les deux principaux
c'est la continuité et la sécurité c'est
exact crette les discontinuités cyclable
est une priorité pour l'instant il ya
6000 kilomètres de confettis cyclables
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas un véritable
réseau et c'est à ce problème qu'il faut
s'atteler pour pouvoir créer 650 km de
pistes cyclables sécurisées et pour un
maximum de sécurité ils font une
signalisation j'imagine oui il faudra à
rendre visible la ligne
rrfb pour les cyclistes mais aussi les
autres usagers pour cela de
signalisation s'entendent ils sont
envisagés un marquage au sol avec un
logo commun pour toutes les lignes du
rer vélo et une civilisé une
signalisation verticale sous forme de
panneaux ou deux totems
en tout cas ces cinq axes devront être
aménagées entièrement d'ici 2025
merci célia pour ces précisions et nous
accueillons justement vincent de golf
bonsoir bonsoir vous être le
coordinateur du projet et donc on vient
d'en parler le rer vélo au sein du
collectif vélos d'île de france je le
rappelle rapidement ce collectif donc a
été créée en mars 2019 et il rassemble
38 associations vélo d'île de france
quel est votre rôle dans ce projet moi
je fais partie petit goût de personnes
craquent à coordonner à l'échelle
régionale le travail de toutes les
associations donc en salle ou volent et
et des associations à tracer des pistes
cyclables qui correspondait à leurs
besoins à travers la région et aussi de
prioriser de faire le choix de faire
dégager quelques grands axes pour
ensuite les porter en est est ce que
c'est facile du coup de s'organiser
parce que il ya beaucoup d'acteurs dans
ce projet il ya la région et de france
mais il ya aussi les collectivités
et puis les 38 associations du coup du
collectif est-ce que c'est facile de
s'organiser avec toutes ses instances
au début on a conçu le projet n'était
d'ailleurs uniquement entre association
s'est créée une phase de mars au 19
jusqu'à décembre 2019 où on a co
construit ensemble avec des centaines de
militants le sel kart like vous voyez
pourra arriver groupé avec une voix
unique auprès des collectivités donc
déjà là c'est vrai que ça a été
pas si facile que ça ou d'accord autant
d'associations autant de territoires sur
une carte unique c'est un premier
travail est maintenant effectivement on
a porté sa cause et sert à la région ils
ont adopté maintenant
ordination entre les élus les aménageurs
et terrasses c'est plutôt côté région ça
se passe et nous on est évidemment
toujours consulter invité à la table
pour discuter discuter des solutions
alors combien coûte ce projet de rer
vélo phone alors non on l'a chiffré à
environ 500 millions d'euros mais une
partie déjà fait donc la région va
apporter un budget de 300 millions
d'euros pour eux pour se construire ce
qu'il manque
et en fait ils subventionnent les
collectivités locales les départements
les communes et les communautés
d'agglomération et c'est à hauteur de
60% des problèmes et donc qu'ils
financent donc vous m'avez dit que
c'était financer donc en partie par la
région
c'est quand même une sacrée somme est ce
que ça compte les équipements qui sont
déjà créés ou c'est uniquement les
nouveaux équipements qui vont être créés
et peut-être le fait de relier les
circuits ils ont alors cette enveloppe
la et de 300 me clarissou importe et et
pour les nouveaux itinéraires alors pour
les nouvelles infrastructures
le but était de s'appuyer sur l'existant
dire que le on va s'appuyer
il ya quand même des très belles pistes
cyclables qui existe partout en
ile-de-france est positif derrière des
voies vertes
donc en fait le but est de réussir à
mener des affaires ce qui manque
et là il apporte ce qui est assez
nouveau du budget justement pour faire
des continuités c'est à dire que si
roman il faut passer la scène et il
pourra porter le budget de faire une
passerelle soit c'est nous tous été un
carrefour quelle pitié et alors on parle
de 2022 pour les premiers axes 2025
peut-être pour la totalité du réseau
est-ce qu'on quand est-ce qu'on pourra
vraiment circuler sur ce réseau sur ce
revers vélo et est ce qu'on peut déjà y
circuler en partie vous et ont circulé
en partie mais justement vous allez vite
vous interrompez et ont conclu but est
d'arriver sur 5 lignes prioritaires à
faire le plus possible plus vite
possible de les continuer et parle même
de 2020 deux pour ces cinq axes donc
vous dans les yvelines vous avez
notamment l'acte qui va vers comtoise
qui va faire l'axé royal en passant par
la défense
puis ils se retrouvent l'extérieur
jusqu'à pontoise et ça d'une manière ou
d'une autre même avec des aménagements
temporaires le but c'est mener cette
continuité en 2020 en sculpture à une
première phase du réseau en 2025 et
ensuite une phase plus complète avec le
réseau entier horizons et bien merci
vincent de golf d'avoir été avec nous
sur ce plateau fait une semaine de
tournée de recrutement en entreprise en
cette période fragilisé par l'épidémie
de kovy de 19
le club d'entreprises face yvelines
ainsi que l' agence d'insertion activity
se sont associés pour créer un job pour
des personnes en recherche d'emploi ont
pu passer des entretiens d'embauché dans
des filières sous tension un reportage
de mélanie poké on va commencer par
présenter devant vous écoutera me
présenter parcours il y a un nom cyrill
décide de changer de métier il délaisse
les cuisines de grands restaurants pour
s'installer derrière un volant après
plusieurs missions temporaires il
aimerait se stabiliser depuis
et janvier ça va faire un an que charge
de travail et ça c'est assez compliqué
d'intérim par ci par là n'ont rien de
concret de contact avec les clients
pouvoir l'extérieur du car l'époque
j'étais à l'intérieur surtout à verser
une belle ville donc ça impressionne ce
jour-là keolis fera passer quatre
entretiens l'opérateur de transport
emploie plus de 280 chauffeur sur son
site versailles et l'entreprise a
accepté de participer aux jo tour depuis
on a des difficultés de à trouver des
candidats
on a une pénurie
deux candidats sur marché du travail lié
tout un tas de choses vous avez eu
beaucoup d'extensions d'offres d'autres
d'autres opérateurs de transport et
et on se retrouve dans une dans une
situation où on doit trouver des
solutions
le job tour a été pensé par le club
d'entreprises face yvelines --l'agence
d'insertion activity ils ont identifié
sélectionnés et accompagner les
candidats donnés aussi l'opportunité à
un maximum de personnes qui sont
éloignés de l'emploi de pouvoir postuler
sur des métiers qu'on considère comme
des métiers qui ont de l'avenir
je leur pose aussi la question comment
vous qu'est ce que vos collègues
pourrait dire de vous et puis donc ça ça
relève un peu de la question vos
qualités vos axes d'amélioration et puis
ensuite on leur donne des conseils
neuf entreprises étaient présentes sur
ce premier job tour du service à
domicile aux transports en passant par
la grande distribution
73 candidats ont ainsi pu tenter leur
chance dans l'actualité également depuis
hier mardi 1er décembre la maison de
retraite dite des chênes verts situés
aux chaînés rocancourt a dû être placé
en confinement sur la cinquantaine de
résidents qu'elle comporte trois ont été
touchés par le comique 19
toutes les visites sont donc interdites
excepté évidemment les interventions de
personnels médicaux paramédicaux et des
auxiliaires de vie et ce jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
un nouveau dépistage sera organisée
lundi 7 décembre prochain sur les
résidents et les personnels ce qui
permettra de lever ou non ce confinement
et on entend parler depuis des mois des
masques transparent ils sont arrivés
dans certains établissements scolaires
et crèches à elancourt la municipalité a
décidé de fournir ces masques à toutes
les crèches et à la classe réservée aux
enfants autistes
astrid bergère est allé à la rencontre
des professionnels de la crèche le petit
prince
cent trente masques transparent
distribués par la ville d'elancourt pour
le personnel de ces crèches et la classe
réservée aux enfants autistes
un investissement nécessaire pour la
municipalité la commune souhaite
vraiment accompagner au mieux les
familles et puis permettre aux enfants
le meilleur du développement possible
on sait très bien que l'effet miroir est
très important c'est un enfant surtout
sur les petits-enfants et de l'ue les
stimulations que qui se passe
les enfants effectivement reproduit ce
qu'ils voient sur l'adulte et bien
souvent c'est comme ça que les enfants
commencent à vocaliser à la crèche du
petit prince on se réjouit de l'arrivée
de ces masques le personnel le porte
pendant les moments d'histoire ou de
continuer quand les enfants nous ont vus
avec ses masques pour la première fois
ils ont été surpris il voyait nos
bouches
donc c'était quelque chose de nouveau de
nous
nouvelle nouveauté de pouvoir voir nos
bouches nos sourires ça fait quand même
partie de notre travail d'insister sur
un lit mimiques de nos expressions et on
a beau mettre tous dans le regard
la bouche peut sourire tout ça ça nous
manquait mais les masques transparent ne
sont pas porter tout au long de la
journée pour des raisons de confort on
les alternent avec les masques normaux
parce qu'il ya aussi des petites choses
qui nous dérange un petit peu dans ces
masques à les porter au quotidien
enfin sur tout âge on sait des masques
qui sont pas remplies xi classe enfin
une matière un peu comme ça un peu
plastifiée donc comme un peu sur les
lunettes avec les max parce que les
autres la buée voilà donc un moment
donné cette buée s'installe et
soit là c'est pas c'est pas très
agréable un bilan donc positif pour les
professionnels les parents et surtout
les enfants
d'autres communes de l'agglomération se
sont également équipés en masques et
transparent et une seconde vie c'est
l'objectif de la ville de montigny le
bretonneux pour trois anciens
établissements scolaires deux gros
chantiers sont donc en cours et un
dernier est déjà terminée état des lieux
avec sia get on go et bixente mais rien
senti steban les chantiers se
multiplient à montigny le bretonneux le
forum des arts charles aznavour est
actuellement l'un des plus gros
chantiers de montigny construit sur
l'ancien collège henri bergson
l'établissement qui veut recentrer une
grosse partie de l'activité culturelle
de la ville ouvrira en septembre
prochain
l'entrée principale présente à son parti
sur la zone rez de chaussée les
activités dédiées aux au théâtre
notamment avec quatre ateliers d'à peu
près 100 mètres carrés chacun et puis
donc toute une partie administrative et
cette ouverture que vous verrez tout à
l'heure sur l'auditorium
le forum sera composé de deux étages au
premier les activités de musique où il
accueillera le conservatoire de montigny
et au second les activités de danse avec
trois studios de plus de 150 mètres
carrés chacun
c'est un espace culturel que nous avons
voulu au coeur d'un projet qui s'intègre
en fin de compte dans l'environnement du
quartier
voilà puisqu'à côté en bas à côté de
l'équipement public
nous allons avoir une vaste esplanade
minérale et arboré à côté un parking
vélo de 69 places et un parking paysager
qui jouxtera l'air de jeu réaménagé pour
un coût de 18,5 millions d'euros autres
chantiers en cours le pôle petite
enfance situé à la place de l'ancien
groupe scolaire albert samain
l'établissement comprendra une nouvelle
crèche de 36 berceaux et un relais
d'assistantes maternelles à les tâches
la petite enfance à montils libre
autorise toujours été quelque chose de
très important parce qu'on a toujours eu
une offre de qualité pour pouvoir
répondre enfin quant aux besoins des
familles il faut savoir que ça
représente 450 berceau sur la ville et
c'est une des meilleures offres
aujourd'hui qui assure les yvelines
ce projet favorisera la mise en relation
entre les familles et les professionnels
du secteur
il coûtera 5,3 millions d'euros et sera
financé à 50% par la mairie et à 50% par
les programmes immobiliers puisque 21
maisons de ville et 15 logements sociaux
vont être construits l'ouverture est
également prévue pour la rentrée est
l'établissement qui est déjà ouvert
depuis plus d'une semaine est un projet
vieux de dix ans la maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle universitaire situé
dans les locaux rénovés de l'ancienne
école jacques prévert cette structure
regroupe 24 praticiens médecins
diététiciens psychologues ou encore
kinésithérapeute
nos médecins de ville aujourd'hui on
sont installés depuis assez longtemps
déjà sur montigny et donc il fallait
penser à l'avenir en termes d'offre de
soins sur la ville cette maison de santé
accueillera aussi des jeunes doctorants
qui viennent de l'université
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se lance dans un service de
trottinettes électriques encore au stade
des réflexions et de la recherche de
l'opérateur le projet devrait se mettre
en place d'ici 2021
les précisions du vice président délégué
aux transports et aux mobilités durables
au micro d'astrid bergère
[Musique]
on a fait voter à l'agglomération et à
l'unanimité
je pense que c'est une bonne chose le
principe justement d'avancé avec des
opérateurs sur les trottinettes et sur
un maillage à l'ensemble des douze
communes sur ce mode qui permet on va
dire de faire le premier ou le dernier
kilomètre donc un mode un mode de
mobilité nouveau durable c'est un
système de trottinette en libre-service
donc là en amont il faudra d'abord une
fois que l'opérateur sera retenu et
choisit définir les stations qui seront
des mots qui seront comment dire
identifié par un marquage au sol avec
des bornes évidemment donc il faudra
voir justement où est-ce qu'elles soient
implantées ou est-ce que cela fait sens
l'idée c'est pas de faire des
déplacements longue durée encore une
fois c'est l'idée du premier et du
dernier kilomètre
c'est une expérimentation d'un an qui
sera reconductible deux fois ce qui nous
permet aussi de voir comment les choses
se passent sur le terrain et puis
ensuite de voir si on y va ou pas dans
la durée sur un mode de déplacement qui
qu'on pourra juger peut-être pérenne et
durable
et puis réajuster les petites choses il
faudra lire et ajustés pour terminer ce
journal on prend la direction du nord
des yvelines
une épicerie sociale et solidaire va
voir le jour en 2021 sur le secteur de
vernouillet et de verneuil-sur-seine
l'association la petite épices hall
composé d'une vingtaine de bénévoles
espère aider à terme plus de 300
personnes dans le besoin
pour cela ils vont cultiver une parcelle
de 300 m² à vernouillet en partenariat
avec la mairie
il faudra également ajouter les produits
donnés par des agriculteurs du secteur
où des grandes surfaces
le tout sera distribué pendant deux demi
journées par semaine à
verneuil-sur-seine uns écoutent
différentes réactions au micro de
michael et demi d'euros ils vont pouvoir
acheter des aliments et d'autres
produits entre 10 et 30% de leurs
fille de marché mais ce n'est pas que ça
c'est un lieu de rassemblement dans un
lieu de vie où on va créer des fonds en
espèces de créer des liens nous nous
engageons sur le long terme puisque de
fait rien que le projet en tant que tel
met à disposition un terrain pour vous
voir
cultiver des produits pour mettre après
à disposition ses longs et le rendement
va pas arriver tout de suite donc bien
sûr qu'on s'inscrit dans la durée c'est
déjà la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi vous retrouverez le 7-8
journal à 18 heures demain présenté par
grégory canale mais avant cela pourrait
revoir cette émission et toutes les
autres sur le site internet tv 78 points
com ou sur notre application mobile tv
68,18 pardon et geci là je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée
[Musique]